philadelphia pennsylvania new york city
new york kippy and uncle hank are coming
home to roost baby october 27th helium
comedy club philly pennsylvania come and
see us and then for the new york comedy
festival we're going to be at gotham
comedy club on november 9th these shows
are gonna sell out get your tickies
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage sure is it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they go to be classy
yeah or if they're just a big old piece
of trash i'm your host holy coming at
you on a beautiful day down here at
antootie's basement she's out at home
depot looking for some new patio
furniture okay for the living room
that's great my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me unamused
as usual he is the ceo of ru garbage
he's international businessman he's a
guy turning wall street upside down
and the big firms are nervous
give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody yeah only dealing in euros
from here on out what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate if you subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are true
through the [ __ ] roof uh and then i
would be a [ __ ] jerk off an [ __ ] a
piece of [ __ ] an idiot don't you say it
if i didn't mention the greatest website
of all time patreon.com
are you garbage
shout out to the conte family the yam
family the founders all the subsidiaries
they're doing the lord's work over there
patreon check it out we love you and how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man he
makes us all look good give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin it's toby mcmullen
what's up dudes
i'm stoked this is gonna be fun it's
gonna be a fun one i know why you're
excited just came in hot today oh yes he
did came in looking real good too yeah
this kid's coming in
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly and i mean
incredibly special guest back with us
today this man is garbage royalty he is
a family member he's on the wall baby
i'm telling you right now he's got keys
to the house i'm giving you that
all right he's one of the stars over
there in the bar stool universe he has
been educated in some of the finest
schools and universities he's from a
fine american family yet somehow
in some way
he is the best example of nature versus
nurture
yeah he's a big old dirtbag
i don't care where you put them folks
this weed is going to grow in the
sidewalk
give it up for the one the only mr john
feidelberg everybody fights what's up it
is my [ __ ] pleasure i'm so happy it's
my first time in the studio i know i
know jacked up you do look tight you
look you look like good yeah looks like
you're about to be in the eternals or
something like that
shows up i had some life changes
recently i i stopped drinking for a bit
i started drinking again but i stopped
drinking
for two months wow that's pretty good
yeah which is it's a nice reminder like
hey you're not an alcoholic yeah i just
went through
i i i was in the hospital and they were
like put your hands out they were
checking me for the shakes and i'd like
somehow you don't have this why were you
in the hospital uh pancreatitis
what is that it's you drink too much
really yeah yeah
yeah no it's it's you poison you drink
poison for
every night for a decade straight yeah
and eventually uh your organs are like
hey man i don't know you gotta [ __ ]
chill out a little bit allegedly
well yeah because here's the deal here's
the [ __ ] rub on pancreatitis no test
for it so i'm just taking the word of
doctors they don't know he's quacking
they don't know what's going on they
were like you got a stomachache i was
like yeah it's real bad get the horse
liver medicine out let's go baby
all right you got pancreatitis i don't
[ __ ] know that so what was the
solution just cut back on the booze it
was they it was so the doctors at the hr
at the er hr
the hell's going on over there
he's at the barber shop
i came for some highlights and a
colonoscopy
the doctors at the er were like you can
never drink again never touch it again
and i was like okay like you proved them
wrong yeah
and then i went john's
story
it's the second i got there to start a
tablespoon at the time every every night
added one more like that [ __ ] like i
think it's like a russian story carry a
one pound heavier pig
john you can't do it i'm telling you
you're not gonna do it i'm chasing a
chicken around 14
with a martini in your hand
but just like i went to see a doctor
three weeks later and the doctor was
like first of all now i gotta be honest
this doctor was in a basement like this
like his office is in a basement i took
the elevator downstairs doctor
when in when in street level hit down to
sea level that's no good no windows no
not unless there's an alien being stored
down there yeah that's [ __ ] shitty
we take no insurance
this sounds like a janitor i'm not gonna
lie
is this is this i'm sorry back this up
is this a specialist is this is no
regular regular primary care my new
primary care because this guy's the
[ __ ] man
he tells you exactly what you wanted to
hear
i i literally was like yo can i sign you
right now off the free agent blocker
yeah i'll start coming in here no matter
what john let me ask you a question are
you having enough chicken wings every
day
i need at least a dozen two dozen out of
here every day john
and
he was like he's i saw he's like what
are you here for and i told him like
that's a follow-up from an er visit and
he's like okay so what did they say and
i was like they told me like i can never
drink again
and he get out of here
but doc i gotta be honest is gonna [ __ ]
up some sponsorships
we're a new amsterdam company so
that's that's almost exactly what i mean
i'm contracting it's almost exactly what
the company told me
i'm contractually obligated to have nine
figures
hey you cashed a check you got to drink
it
he was like he's like he goes they told
you what he was very flamboyant and i
was like
he had like he like put this hip to the
side like he was on broadway yeah they
told you what started shaking at cosmo
[Laughter]
they said i can't drink he goes listen i
want you to live the best and most
fulfilling life possible and if you
can't have a beer if you die 138 that's
what happens okay he said you can't have
that it's like all right that's fine
like whatever um and he was like you can
start drinking this weekend if you want
that's like
geez don't have to tell me bravo open up
a documentary so that was that was two
weeks ago and uh i mean i've been uh
i've been off it for a little bit i got
off the piss for a bit i got um
off the pit what's that off booze yeah
that's trashy
that's [ __ ] british bro that's that's
classy i'm off to drink yeah i bought
off drinks
then i gotta quit dip too stop chewing
tobacco that's great that one's been
three months but i saw you were smoking
sick started smoking cigarettes
bro i was i was outside just leaning
against your building smoking a
cigarette before i came up here i should
have called me four years old in 2021
started smoking no 33. 33 years old in
the middle of the middle of a [ __ ]
lung collapsing pandemic he starts
smoking bernies
hi i'm john feidelberg and smoking and
ketamine turned my life around
i like i like told someone that is your
doctor in a basement because he should
be
i told someone that like
like braggadociously i was like yeah i
haven't had a drink in a while quit dip
two
it's like bites like i did start smoking
cigarettes and they were like what like
it was that's crap i was so proud i do
have one vice that i just picked up it's
[ __ ] the one that kicked out in the
90s
it's the one the world the whole world
got hip to yeah in 88
kids going retro
i've always been an old soul
tie-dye shirts and unfilters
all right we got to go back on this
because i'm slightly concerned so you
weren't feeling well mm-hmm all right
and so you went you so you went to how
did you end up in the er got that bad it
was it was just like it was no it was in
the it was in the afternoon it was
actually during an interview okay um
[ __ ] what's his name [ __ ] was like
go to the hospital it was uh so how long
have you been acting
screaming at a guy on zoom who plays
frodo
um
who plays frodo
elijah wood elijah wood
go to the [ __ ] hospital elijah what
told you to go to the hospital all right
hey you're like the chosen one you
listen to that guy i kept i kept going
in the middle of the interview like i'll
just flex back and go
[Laughter]
dude he refers to he refers to shooting
lord of the rings like someone refers to
uh going to harvard where it's like i
was up at school in cambridge he was
like yeah i was at work over in new
zealand like we know what you were doing
dude you said you were filming lord of
the rings
i was doing some work in new zealand
yeah we're aware
yeah we all saw it two terrorist
resources
so you didn't feel well so i didn't feel
well just went to the hospital and they
they kind of did all their [ __ ] but
here's what happened in the hospital
you went to the er that's different yes
yes er all right so what did they test
you for check you out for
give you like an mri and stuff like that
nope nope the ultrasound ultrasounded me
up okay yep um and that was it that was
the only test they gave me they're like
all right we're gonna we're gonna put
you in the hospital for a little bit now
that they ask how often
so they found something they yeah they
found pancreatitis acute pancreatitis
supposedly
yeah
so their [ __ ] degrees say i don't
know i have my own suspicions about what
it was i think i was just dehydrated my
dad and mom agree
oh you want to use it as the insurance
company
get them out
my dad called me the morning after i got
admitted he goes do you need to go to
rehab i said i said no i don't think so
i'm all set and i went home but the guy
who needs rehab would say yeah
he goes all right just checking and hung
up and then i go home the next day
and i'm home for three hours you want a
beer i was like bro
20 hours ago you called me i was gonna
go to rehab now i'm on the couch in pain
in my [ __ ] hospital socks still and
you go do you need a beer
looks like you could use a cold one
take some of that worry off your face
but the uh so they admitted me and um
i [ __ ] it so doctors have this thing
now where doctors don't wear white
jackets anymore i don't know if they
ever did i don't know if it's a tv or
movie thing but i can't tell who's a
doctor and who i'm bringing this whole
system there they're all in fact anybody
can get a finger on my ass
you [ __ ] jump to the end of the story
wait what
dude so i'm in there for two days right
they've taken my vitals probably seven
separate times right they come in and
hook me up with the [ __ ]
blood pressure thing put the [ __ ]
oxygen level thing on my finger check my
temperature yada yada yada yada one
morning come this doctor comes in and i
just hit him with a what's up bro
and because he's into scrubs he's look
he's a young looking dude in scrubs
figured he's a nurse pulls out his thing
he goes actually it's dr timuron
i was
yeah this is how he gets into [ __ ] i
don't know the more the [ __ ] body and
uh and he's like he's actually starting
to timer i was like all right my bad
whatever you know he talks to me for a
little bit and from that point forward
every time they took my vitals they took
it from my ass
and i think he was so pissed off that i
called him bro rather than what vitals
are they taking in your ass my
temperature yeah temperature rectal yeah
the best way to do it they were doing my
mom did it from that i had seven
shout out to patty
i had seven different mouth temperatures
and then my last three all [ __ ]
rectally
and he and at one point i caught him
peeking around the corner right
i swear to [ __ ] god and he and we
locked the eyes deeper deeper
we locked up the lipstick on them
you know the position you get in when
you're getting things in your ass how
would you say no go mouth go mouth i
well i'm gonna tell a [ __ ] nurse what
to do during a pandemic they're heroes
okay
i've seen you could have done
yeah i walk out tell the truth what to
do too no thanks
and they um
they he comes out he's like he's like
actually he doesn't need it that way he
doesn't need it that way and he goes
unless do you care and i was like no i
don't care like i just want to get the
[ __ ] out of here but i wouldn't hate it
if you i don't know maybe close that
door because the door was wide open yeah
or i don't know shut this curtain and in
the middle of current jesus we didn't do
it in the waiting room
it was like i could just see outside i'm
[ __ ] fetal position my boxer is down
i can just make eye contact with people
walk into the hallway nice you're
[ __ ] crazy
that's bonkos but you feel better you
feel great you look great you're good
you have more life to you yeah yeah
that's unfortunate
i was really trying to do the other
thing it's really trying to go the other
way here's the thing though you look
tight you look like you've been working
out and this didn't happen in a couple
couple weeks or ago yeah it did yeah
jesus i don't know but every time we see
him he's got like a baggy sweatshirt on
too i think maybe he might have just
been hiding that tight box
not showing off in the office i
understand it i just took a sexual
harassment quiz today so no i don't i
know when i'm around the ladies to keep
my shirt on
whatever you call them training training
you want to [ __ ] me no no no
i know you can't announce to the office
now i'd like to see more half nude women
in here that was an actual question
really yeah i was like uh sam they used
semi-nude not half nude but it was uh
i'd like to see more semi-nude women
around the office from a radio station
[Laughter]
opie and anthony running the [ __ ]
can you take a co-worker into a monster
truck show they always feel like setups
because i remember i was getting a job
at a at a supermarket i had to take like
a 30 question quiz of like what would
you do if you caught someone stealing
have you and i was like this old let him
go
you know what you pay me right exactly
but i'm like who's answering the wrong
question
who were you tripping up to be like yeah
i still at work yeah i'd hate to admit
it but i didn't read any of the stuff i
was supposed to read before i got to the
common sense questions yes never but i
used to work at gnc i used to have
friends steal stuff on purpose i feel
like everybody stole everything from gnc
dude it was like everybody knew somebody
like my buddy works here and get you you
know 50 gallons of creativity i've never
known anybody that worked at gnc and
that's complete garbage you are oh dude
i worked at gnc i worked at a gnc in
east providence rhode island were you
bigger were you yoked up i was tired
yeah how are you i was like i mean i
wasn't like a [ __ ] you know you
weren't mistaking me for mr olympia but
i work out
and um and i would have friends come in
and buy [ __ ] and then walk out the door
and immediately come in and return it
because once someone returned something
then it was opened and it's a it's a
food product
so you can and then we just all take it
home
yeah the smart saved a lot of college
money
[Laughter]
oh i love it
glad you're feeling good thanks you
drinking a lot of water i always drink
all i ever drink was alcohol or water
i don't drink
coffee soda juice
my mom didn't let us drink sugar as a
kid she's like no you just drink water
all right yeah that worked out
got him this far the only the only sugar
we could have was the martinelli's the
uh the fake champagnes
yeah
shout out special day every day is new
year's day i'll tell you that right now
when they got a bottle of martinez
i like the apple grape myself but the
apple grape yeah they got an apple i
don't even know what flavors i had i
just had to drink straight apples
probably straight out i like you i'm
predicting straight apple family right
up the middle
um
what do you drink what is what is your
what is your
cocktail whiskey whiskey on the rocks
neat just whiskey and you were having
one or two of those about per day one or
two glass yeah no oh you weren't yeah it
wasn't so you weren't drinking that much
oh i was drinking more than last oh yeah
yeah [ __ ] yeah he squeaky squat at the
one to two he wasn't i thought you were
saying oh no not that no the pandemic we
were hitting it
pandemic we were doing half bottle do a
bottle at night really yeah
i was like world's going down i'll go
down with it for sure
with a fine single ball
all right well that's good
they give you any pills or anything like
that nothing at all damn not a [ __ ]
thing all right well get out they were
hitting me with they
yeah it'll get you'll get you [ __ ]
you can't [ __ ] for a couple of days
dude i didn't even know what the lotted
was but then they were um
what was it i asked for more because i
was still in pain yeah and they're like
you can't do anymore with a lot of we
can give you morphine though i was like
oh i'm above morphe
i thought i thought morphy was a top of
the pyramid they were like nah we'll
give you more penises yeah hook that up
sure morphine's pretty good more if
he'll get you going i haven't i had an
idea i got that icy warm feeling cooking
through your body it feels like
christmas eve all the time
it's so good
i had an angiogram not that long ago and
they were
uh they go in through your arm to look
at your heart
and um they gave me they said i would be
in a twilight sleep so i'm like all
right cool i'll get to i'll be aware of
it you know i'm gonna get to enjoy it i
won't just be asleep hey [ __ ] real
stingy with it i'm like yo buddy
let's go [ __ ] yeah top me off over
here
make sure the next one's full right
that's not six ounces i'll tell you that
right now let's go buddy
yeah when somebody's controlling it
you're in a safe environment like that
that's how i want to do ketamine
ketamine's hot in the streets now that's
real a lot of people are doing it
everyone's talking about ketamine i want
someone who
i doesn't have to be like in a real safe
environment i'm not [ __ ] about it
it could be a race basically if you have
ketamine right i always do it
he has to go to the er for pancreatitis
they say he might be an alcoholic they
put him in the hospital he quits
drinking for a couple of months back on
the horse start smoking now he's on the
prowl
if i say something that might affect the
pancreas why don't you stop me and just
started
lifting stuff off mushrooms weed i was
like just going through the whole list
yeah he's like no you can do all that
now a big thing i always lie to them you
know because
you know i'd lie to myself a lot but
when they asked you how often do you
drink and how much were you completely
honest with you probably didn't even
[Laughter]
i tell the doctors i quit smoking a few
months ago that's my go-to oh yeah yeah
when i put a few months ago
how often do you go to the doctors i've
been going a lot because i just got
insurance so i've been going through
around i'm getting all my [ __ ] done
getting through work see but that's you
don't [ __ ] ask questions like really
go what's the thing they tell lawyers
don't ask a question you know the answer
to yeah yeah yeah that's that's what
you're asking doctors this is my first
they need to know that no they asked why
worst case worst case scenario you died
this guy's walking the plank as it is
yeah that's the worst case scenario i
know so i just started making it so bad
this is this that time visiting that
primary care was my first time at a
doctor since
2000
since 2000 and
i've been to the doctor in a long time
11 yeah what i was a little surprised
about i would assume that you had nice
insurance i do you go that you would go
to a yearly checkup regularly look at
him what do you think he looks like the
bad guy in sonic what are you talking
about
i'm not going to the doctor this guy
plays it fast and loose he just asked
you for ketamine i don't remember i
don't i don't remember that bozo having
those highlights
nice this is sun not highlighted this is
the 80s baby coming back at you that's
the mo that's detroit you have money and
you're doing something
aren't you sponsored by a salon as well
he puts an error because
erica fleischman plays with salon does
not do colors she just does cuts but the
i might have to go there oh she'll take
care yeah did you have to is it part of
the ingredients or the part of the steps
of sun in that you have to uh get the
sun at a community pool is that usually
how that works
here you want to hear some real [ __ ]
garbage [ __ ] about sun that i learned
you don't it does it's not the sun that
does it actually
so you can just do it with a blow dryer
i think i knew that i did think you
could just [ __ ] sit in your apartment
and get getting some [ __ ] tips
guys i gotta say it's not every day you
meet a master this is pretty excellent
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
all rolled into one with just a touch of
catwoman
he plays by his own rules as vital this
guy walked into the dojo with a black
belt on him
y'all hiring
take on all of cobra kai and larusso all
at once
kippy let's talk about our good friends
over there a ladder a ladder yup there's
been a lot of shake-ups and industries
lately and ladder is doing that to the
insurance game maybe yeah uh before
ladder if you want to get life insurance
you have to drive across town sit
through a stupid sales pitch fill out a
ton of paperwork none of that with
ladder nah you get fast affordable term
life insurance without ever leaving your
home term life-based 100 digital when
you apply for 3 million or less in
coverage no doctors no needles no
paperwork you set it and forget it it's
a couple of bucks right now i don't know
if i'm contractually allowed to say that
so if you're
uh if you'll be if you're between the
ages of 20 to 60 wide spread on that 20
to 60. big range uh you need a big demo
you need coverage and you want to team
up with a company that's redeeming life
insurance choose
ladder uh go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
r life l-a-d-d-e-r-life com slash
garbage ladderlife.com
garbage do it gang this podcast is
sponsored by better help do you have
anything in your life that's holding you
back from being happy well better help
can help you can start communicating
with a professional licensed therapist
in under 48 hours it's not a self-help
line all right something like that we're
talking licensed professional therapists
in the privacy of your own home yeah you
can log in anytime anywhere send a
message to your counsel you'll get a
timely thoughtful response plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room hear anybody
talking that whole thing that nobody
hears you're crying next door you know
what i mean in fact so many people have
been using betterhelp they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
look at that they're hiring baby they're
booming business is booming over here
better help uh special offer for all you
garbage listeners you get 10 off your
first month at betterhealth.com not one
time two times your first month at
betterhelp.com
garbage
you know what i love
helix
you know i do
shout out to the helix mattress love it
and the good folks that worked there yes
because they take the guessing game
out of pick of the mattress yeah let me
ask you a question you used to go to the
mattress store walk around like a bozo
buzzing on a bed that a bunch of other
people have laid on your mouth you know
the last time they showered no helix got
you all straightened out take the quiz
online takes two minutes matches you
with the nice bed whether you sleep cool
you sleep hot or you sleep fat i sleep
fat and they got they got stuff for the
big boys and then you guys are the big
boys the big gals out there too got my
vote uh me and my lady did it they were
nice enough to send us a mattress um so
we took the two-minute quiz we got set
up with the twilight mattress game
[ __ ] changer let me tell you guys the
best sleep i ever had in my life i
always had some some idiot mattress that
i got from my mom or somebody a sister a
stole from a college dorm room something
first adult mattress i've ever had
home run grand slam best sleep in my
life so if you're looking for a mattress
take the quiz order the mattress that
you're matched to comes right to your
door ship for free never have to go to
the mattress store again go to
helixsleep.com garbage take the quiz
match it send it 10-year warranty
uh best thing you get to try it out for
a hundred nights 100 nights risk-free
what so even pick it up if you don't
love it but i'm telling you it's got the
kippy seal of approval you're gonna love
it uh helix is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners they're crazy over
there at helix sleep.com garbage one
more time 200 off all mattress or up to
200 off all mattress orders two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com garbage now back to the show
you were telling us i saw you posted on
instagram whatever story of you drunk
eating a banana a bunch of bananas
smoking cigs and some guy goes hey feets
i love you and you're like it's funny
it's fights actually
i didn't want that kind of go home oh
wait a minute hold on there was a there
was a video of that no i heard you tell
the story animated
oh yeah that that drawing was really
cute yeah yeah i looked like a [ __ ]
strung out dug funny
which is painfully accurate for what i
really said i got news for you brother
yeah i was at the bar i just took a walk
because i people thought that was people
were surprised by that part where like i
go out for walks all the time when i'm
with friends i like need a break from
hanging out with people and i'll just go
yeah that's kind of weird that's weird i
think that's one of those things like
you you get a little [ __ ] your social
battery gets a little drained like i'm
gonna go for a walk how long are these
walks not too long ten minutes i guess i
go out to smoke a lot but not
everybody's gonna go what do you do go
around the block yeah i go around the
block go pop in a convenience store slam
the water eat a banana i i'm embarrassed
of the healthy things i do in my life so
that's why i was
like sitting by the trash barrel instead
of in front of the
you take a five minute break from
drinking yeah a decade you think a
banana is a healthy thing
like if you were just like hey guys i'm
going to go grab a banana real quick
that one's going to be like what are you
doing no i think what are you wearing
i don't want the bartender to see me
yeah so i was i was hanging out on the
corners on the corner 28th and third and
i was just like i didn't want to be in
front of the bar because they'd see me
you hang out over there a lot right yeah
yeah yeah that's over the factory i saw
i saw him at a show there i was just i
just did that show two weeks ago it's a
great a great spot
i was walking out of the show and he's
sitting he's got like [ __ ] nine
potato skins in front of him
he's like follow me i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you doing here
the uh
it's like when i take like a
multivitamin at the office i do it like
under my desk because that's weird you
tell everybody it's
but i don't like if i'm [ __ ] doing
like
healthy [ __ ] because then people are
like oh it becomes a thing with your
friends like oh look who's trying to
better himself it's embarrassing she's
doing lines of emergency
dude no one
i was curious
um what did you have for breakfast this
morning hold on put a pin in that for a
second okay you were just talking about
taking the pills do you take
what's the order of the pill is it water
then pill or pill put some water pill
water
pill water pill water yeah
what do you [ __ ] what is it like
putting milk in cereal that's insanity
if you're doing water in the middle a
lot of the pills
to me it's like a fish he just taken in
everything yeah we just spoke with mr
jim norton who takes a sip of the water
and then sucks the pill and swallows it
and a lot of people in the comments were
saying that's what they do that's insane
that's what i do with salty treats wait
what oh actually no i know i still go
food first i like goldfish cheez-its
[ __ ] like that i put i put a handful of
the cheese until they go over to my
mouth and then while they're in there i
have a sip of water oh yeah that's much
classic
of course
that's how those snacks are supposed to
be oreos i'll do i'll do it with
everything dude can you kick it up a
notch do it with a nice cold [ __ ]
coca-cola i don't blow your phone i'm
saying my mom would be pissed
they go they go drink first then pill no
no it's crazy
that's nuts you're a dry pill man i
assume that if you need it to right i i
can if necessary you know i
i have bottles of water around the house
so it's a really good lock on the
bathroom door at the bar
and get it down real quick
what did you have for breakfast
for breakfast today i had um
i just do like smoothies okay i have
like uh i have like pre-packaged
smoothies well that's healthy that's
what i did myself a little kale little
spinach pre-packaged what do you mean
like i just put them in i put like
little bags in the freezer and then of
the actual already smoothie or just the
ingredients and then i put in a blender
i don't know john that sounds pretty
healthy and pretty responsible it is
it's lame
it's awful we got a narc over here just
to be clear when i go to ask you what i
have before i go to fall asleep that's a
totally different thing it's like it's
like 10 000 skittles sour patch
i got a bag i got a [ __ ] pocket in my
bed sheets that i fill with sour patch
kids and justin's peanut butter cups and
i just kind of roll over while i watch
tv in bed and i eat that [ __ ] that's a
classy peanut butter crop though
those justin's about nine nine bucks a
clip don't blow your [ __ ] hair back
dude people try and argue with me they
say reese's are better oh it's not even
close it is justin's inaudible oh
reese's is fine i'm
yeah yeah you feel the crack it's not a
reese's will bend in your mouth justin's
cracks
and i'm a dark chocolate guy too dark
chocolate's nice yeah dark chocolate
they do it good you do come from a good
family so that makes sense that's true
dark chocolate just happened one day it
was like i was a milk chocolate milk
chocolate milkshake for me it was for
like europeans how old are you i am 33.
yeah i think that how about how long
have you been on the two three years ago
yeah that makes sense too right around
30.
yes
dark chocolate with sea salt
will blow your [ __ ] hair back oh my
god that's how when i quit smoking i
would just do like three of those a day
[Laughter]
dark chocolate's tight when you were a
kid that [ __ ] was like it might have all
been cat food right right it was poison
brutal there was the hershey had a dark
and i remember yeah just no it was like
eating ashes or something i even
remember when my mom be making chocolate
chip cookies and she'd be using the
semi-sweet morsels having a handful of
those before they were in the cookie
like what the [ __ ] is this you know how
bad something has to taste for like a
kid to be like no i'm not doing the
candy yeah and that somehow they found
the ingredient to that but then it
switches it's like that thing in your
brain where cilantro is a cilantro yeah
some people taste like soap yeah i i
taste so you die
don't do it i used to hate it now i love
it
oh i didn't know that gene could flip
yep still smoking cigs though
what cigarettes do you have probably i
just have because i'm because i'm not
even like back on cigarettes i started
smoking is it american spirits no
they're marlboros
oh yeah yeah they're not not reds all
right gentlemen over here yeah i thought
i was gonna say american spirits i was
like i heard those take like 25 minutes
i'm a fastball i gotta get it and get
out just get my buzz hot bananas
i got bananas to eat in doctors
i got pacquiao titus
wow all right
what a [ __ ] bonkers what a tornado
this kid's nuts
also too i've said because we obviously
you were one of the i think you were the
second bar stool person we've had we had
on i think he's after after kate
and then
we've had a bunch obviously afterwards
uh
but you are still anybody
asks who we've had especially from
barstool you came on and you were like
there's no way the only person to ever
come on the show in the [ __ ] two
years we've been doing it or whatever
who's come on and said
i just want to state there's no way i'm
garbage
that's what he said there he goes
there's absolutely no way i'm going to
be guarded he's a madman and within 14
seconds of a meeting i'm like you're
nuts have you wet the bed recently no no
no no no no no no no nothing no
i would have been a long time pandemic
i think i don't think so okay i don't
think so i don't know for sure
we don't have all these
kind of all my data in front of me yeah
i i think it's been a while okay
there's a stain on my new mattress
but i think it is i think it's sweat
sweat's not yellow i'm pretty sure it's
like a sweater you're doing burpees so i
gotta i got a new mattress for the
during the pandemic it's a helix
mattress
is it nice it is a helix
garbage and i stripped i stripped the
bed
recently and i i was looking at it and i
was like where
the [ __ ]
did that come from
because i don't remember
there's look i just gotta stay in my new
mattress and i'm just gonna leave it at
that okay okay who where it came from
who who amongst us unfortunately we
can't leave it at that
so let's say here's the bed about where
would it be if an average-sized human
being was it in the genital region it
was in the head general or feet region i
was going to say nipple it's nipple
region that's so you're lactating
it's good news now it's a bigger let's
say
broad strokes
vaguely nipple the knee
that's the middle third that's
why your penis is in there my penis is
in the area but it's also where i sweat
the most
it's also covering all my sweat glands
i'm going pee yeah without even putting
eyes on it i'm going plus to be honest i
don't really care where it is in the bed
because this screwball probably sleeps
in all different weird positions i
actually very very often i would say and
by very often i mean 90 plus i sleep on
the couch really yeah my air
conditioning my bedroom broke
and that was back in
april may june start of summer couching
it and i just didn't feel like fixing it
and i haven't fixed it to this day you
can get a new one right sure can that's
a whole thing though yeah
i'm a big couch sleep i've been a couch
sleeper for
[Laughter]
as a kid my dad and my mom were the kind
of people who'd be like wake up go to
bed no i'm in bed where i fell asleep i
am in bed i would get woken up every
night at like 10 45 or 11 years i'm like
go up to bed i'm like i'm [ __ ]
snoozing how about you guys go to bed
i'm i'm the asleep one here don't wake
that guy up go to bed you know it's a
real good time you're laying on the
couch on your side and you're facing out
it's the middle of the night and you do
that roll over and throw the leg over
the couch
it's like a month in switzerland
good night okay so what's the stain
situation on the couch couch is good
couple couple spots of melted chocolate
but that's
also come on also by the sweat glands
yeah
i i have for sure falling asleep with
like uh
a peanut butter cup or some bunch of
crunch you're like an alcoholic toddler
that's crazy he's nuts you don't smoke
weed do you smoke weed not really no do
you think edibles uh i did for a while
for like like i felt like a month last
january on edibles and uh i go to bed so
late that i would i would time do you go
to bed at 3am every day give or take
yeah then what time you got to be at the
office uh whatever yeah yeah
what time do you get there like ballpark
tennis
give a blanket on the couch with you uh
yeah
a pillow from the bed on the couch
because next level
that that's sick day [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's fantastic i'm like a [ __ ] old
irish alcoholic who like like they're in
the middle of a divorce but they don't
have the courage to tell everyone
that's a little jack donaghy there
shout out to donaghy but the um
but [ __ ] what were you saying before
that
you get up you go to bed at three oh oh
yeah with the edibles i was uh i take
him i was taking him at like 2 30 3
o'clock in the morning and then zonking
out and then the next day i'd [ __ ]
drag ass all day and i couldn't figure
out why and i was like you're so high i
was like i think i'm like in the middle
of a real depressive spiral and then
finally someone was like dude i think
you've just been a hot yeah
that's like you're right i'm only doing
400 milligrams a day what the heck i was
high on edibles until 7 pm every day and
it was killing me pressure insulin is
probably [ __ ] going up and down left
and right
all right let's get into some questions
somali garbage questions yes guys so as
you know when you join the patreon we
will answer your garbage question on air
just the best way to do it because we
have so many submissions
uh and we got a couple of heaters for mr
fetelberg right here yeah talk about
looking out you got one of the best
right here i know this guy's bonkos
uh all right this one's from hugh uh i
haven't had a question right ever apply
for a job and that you did not have the
qualifications or experience for
feidelberg just left
might be a little snag over at lennox
hill hospital
oh that's the hospital i was at
it
um really you were in lenox hill yeah
very classy yeah i was i went to the er
in greenwich village and then they put
me in the uh
the hospital up there did they take you
in an ambulance from there
really
[Applause]
the [ __ ] ambulance driver goes sorry
it took so long i was like i wasn't
allowed to hit the woo if only there's a
[ __ ] magic button in that car to get
us [ __ ] there faster you're not dying
you're just an alcoholic i can't turn on
the woo legally
dude you've ridden in an ambulance
that's [ __ ] like two weeks ago
it was two weeks before that too for
what
did i was this it was the same route i
was going from the lenox hillyard to
lenox hill i woke up one morning just
looking like a pelican i had this huge
[ __ ] like glitter in my like they
never got to the bottom of that one dude
take an uber you called the ant i i
wanted to no no no no no i live by the
grand chill er okay and uh i just walked
there and then they transferred me again
from there to
the hospital on the upper east side
right so you've been in an ambulance
twice do you think i have to hit 9-1-1
on myself
come
[Laughter]
but but you've been in an ambulance
twice in the last six months that's a
correct correct
that's a new question this kid's
last time you're in an ambulance
for what this kid's worth every penny
this kid's [ __ ] gorgeous
he's gold
i never thought of it like that that is
so trash
most people go their whole lot most
normal people go their whole lives out
ever
you did it twice recently one for you
don't know the reason and the other ones
are drinking too much dude
even if i'm dying i'm taking a cab i'm
not getting
cause you're looking as they're going by
like oh what's going on
don't look nice no it's not [ __ ] all
over it's like in the movies
[Laughter]
yeah plus nobody moves for you in the
city yeah dude especially without the
woo-woo's he's [ __ ] sitting in
traffic
at like 5pm on a wednesday trying to get
uptown takes [ __ ] forever oh because
you like it all because you like whiskey
just so you know a gurney not
comfortable at all you got metal bars
getting shoved up your back and ass the
whole ride it's [ __ ] brutal brutal
hey can i get some ketamine leaves for
the ride
take the edge off
but uh to answer the question
i have never applied for a job
that i wasn't qualified for
there was a time when i earlier on when
i moved to new york where i was like
guess what how old were you when you
moved to new york uh i was like five six
years ago now so like
did you come to work for barcelona yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um so the whole
company down here i think five and a
half years ago we'll call it something
like that and uh
it's probably a year or two into it and
i was just like this is i'm not doing
anything this sucks
and my idea was that i am going to
join a big brother program
so i tried to join a big brother program
in brooklyn that poor bastard and i
applied i
applied and they were just like
nah we don't think you got what it takes
kid really
like i just want to hang out with a
homeless kid and they were like
i'm trying to find someone who's on my
i'm way to learn a couple of pointers
look i'm just trying to get someone to
keep me on the straight and arrow don't
you have a seven-year-old who's home
alone
jesus i'm not sure you know what the big
brother program is i'm looking for a kid
to straighten me out a little bit hey
look i've been drinking too much on
friday nights i need a reason to take it
easy get up on a saturday morning hang
out with a child in a park and they're
like bro yeah that's what that's what
parents want is feidelberg sniffing
around hey lady i saw i saw sleepers
last night and i feel guilty
[Laughter]
it wasn't technically big brother but it
i forgot i honestly forget what it was
but it was
that was the general [ __ ] they didn't
want they didn't they didn't want your
kind
yeah you are right it wasn't it wasn't
big brother big sister no it was like i
i i keep the other guy i could
figure it out but it was you just hang
out with him on saturday
hear it this guy will do
[Laughter]
we take any dirt bag off the street
that's even more trash that's what i'm
saying
an off-brand big brothers big sisters
you couldn't get in
how'd gnc hire you
would you july to get in there that's
what i want to know
[ __ ] shirts on backwards you're
wandering around
oh my god
[Laughter]
this kid's [ __ ] screw balls
it's nuts
um this one's a pro this is from dallas
ever had a credit card with your
favorite sports team logo printed on it
you got a red sex card right i've never
had that because i've always thought
that was garbage yeah it's a great
question yeah yeah i've never had that i
can't tell you a credit card scheme i
used to run though
first off get yourself a little brother
i've never asked the kids for id
back when i was in college and actually
it was like right post college i was i
was working barcelona's making like 500
bucks a month and no goddamn money 500
bucks a month yeah
[Laughter]
and i used to get [ __ ] this was like
at the start of you know like the visa
[ __ ] gift cards sure it was like
those were just getting started oh this
is right up my ass i love a good visa
gift card scam lay it on people didn't
realize really realize what they were
sure so i'd get like 15 gift cards
and go into a bar oh yeah i think we
might have talked about it
on your show yeah
big fan of that yeah they wouldn't run
them well they just run it to make sure
there's like that there's like a dollar
over there and then i drink and then i
just leave yeah
wow that's that's it's yeah
i can't believe that brothers didn't
want you i i've been paying for that
ever since i started making money we're
like now i tipped through the room sure
but back in southie in uh
2010 to 2014.
now yeah four year run 2010 to 2012.
okay there were some bartenders who
probably got [ __ ] i apologize
hey it happened it's every man for
himself they were desperate times back
then these are still looking for him
can't go near the capital one the gift
card bandit struck again
this time it was at o'malley saloon
there's some bartender with valued
customer on his kill
john q card holder
we were going to ask you uh what is your
credit card situation now do you have
good credit i have good credit right now
i can tell you exactly what my credit is
right now please go ahead
but your credit score or how much credit
you have well how much
how much credit do you
have i don't know what that means like
what you what's your credit card limit
like if you could like
a thousand five thousand two thousand
ten thousand yeah ten ten all right i
thought it'd be more but okay i i don't
ask i don't spend i like my credit card
i [ __ ] i just pay it right away okay
i've never like
i don't need any more than that i don't
like
bottle of whiskey's 40 bucks
one a day though
do you have an american express card i
do not never apply for one really i
don't like i don't really spend money
that much so i i have
my credit score i didn't know that i i
don't know what those things mean so my
credit score
whatever
um but yeah that's it's okay it's time
that's good that's good
his we both just got ours increased uh
for a long time he was 500 bucks and i
was 200 bucks
but we just we just got it increased i
just got i got a visa box card
your mom has to add money to it every
month these are little guys
a little kickstarter a little training
yeah that was that's what everybody said
like i just kept getting denied and they
were like you have to get one of those
pre-paid ones where you put like 500
bucks yeah then spend that 500. i didn't
have a bank account up until i think
five years ago was when i had an actual
bank account yeah dude see i used to
have i had in college i had one of those
like emergency credit cards
that like
i didn't use for emergencies because i'm
a [ __ ] nerd yeah and i'd use it for
everything and then when my mom realized
i started using it for everything she
stopped paying it but never told me so
when i was like 30 years old i had awful
credit because of all that i was like
i've never even had a credit card how
can i have bad credit and then my mom
was like oh yeah i just you have like
four thousand dollars from college you
owe back i was like what the [ __ ] lady
we're gonna tell you about any of this
at any point that's pretty crazy i
respect the move
that's [ __ ] challenging checkers i
like that she puts the screws to you
yeah it's good to know that somebody out
there is she's like well you thought you
were going to the movies on me all
college i'm like i'll ruin the next
seven years of your life
you think i care john i don't care
i hope wedding crashes was good
did you enjoy [ __ ] couples retreat
john
that was an all right movie it was like
when i went to see alone it was one of
the more depressing asks you'll ever see
do a to a 16 year old working in the
movie theater you at least got to buy
two tickets
for couples retreat you don't say one
listen here you lady who shots a hot
topic [ __ ] run the card run the
ticket i'll get the [ __ ] out of your
face
that's with vince vaughn right yes it's
no breakup but it's all right yeah no
it's all right uh favreau's in it
uh bateman bateman faison love melee
ackerman love yeah i love faison love
um
all right let's see here uh oh this is
one we wanted to talk to you put uh this
was a big divisive one a few weeks or
last week uh do you put your pants on oh
oh i i i weighed in on this okay do you
play i forget and then you're you're
team foley
underwear socks pants he probably goes
socks and then gets in the shower
puts a pot on his head
who knows what this guy does i put my
tub socks on
wait so what do you do i go um
i go actually i usually go okay here is
the thing i usually go
socks first
before underwear for underwear this
guy's [ __ ] think how do you get
kookier
than that because here's the deal i get
dr i don't take the time i don't have
good towels you know like some towels
dry some towels don't i just i just
bought good towels okay like they came
today but good towels are usually [ __ ]
towels like the knife i use brooklyn and
they're fantastic
brook linen is a nice towel you don't i
don't you don't like the thick fancy
ones that are soft you like one with a
little bit a little bit i like something
like [ __ ] sandpaper that'll get it
off yeah and i can't get it off here the
water that's kind of scary this guy's
out of ten all the time
i don't get the water off yet like it's
bad or something he's a crazy connector
take an extra
[Laughter]
he's at the hospital he's not at the
hospital he's everywhere
you should be running a chocolate
factory in england
because this guy's [ __ ] screwy
holy [ __ ]
all right
here's what happens i don't [ __ ] try
i hate trying i hate taking the time to
dry so when i get dressed i'm usually
still damn me too i'm damp at worst i'm
damp okay i'm not wet but i'm damn sure
now if you get dressed damp if you put
your underpants on damp you you kind of
it just keeps that dampness in i know
what you're talking about for a long
time almost all but the socks are the
same for me the socks are the hardest
thing to put on if they're but the feet
are the easiest thing to dry
the feet dry fast the feet the foots are
quick dry there's a method to his
madness
so what i do is when i put my socks on
i sit on my bed naked obviously you're
out of the shower i'm out of the shower
you're not 100 dry or you are drunk i'm
not 100 dry but i sit in my bed
and because when i'm sitting down i
guess [ __ ] everything opens up
the sheets dry
the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] the whole
undercarriage the whole thing gets dry
a mess why it's [ __ ] clean i just got
out of the shower just scrubbed it up
it's the cleanest my [ __ ] ever is
it's post shower i would start there
maybe with the stain investigation
yeah just fyi oh it is always where i
sit in that area right there there you
go but it [ __ ] tinctures it absorbs
everything because if you can get
dressed damp it [ __ ] ruins your day
the [ __ ] is always the wettest it's
always the wettest but when you sit down
and sometimes sometimes i'll be nice
about it it's not a good point sometimes
i'll lay the towel down and i'll sit on
the towel but that's the towel's already
wet though it's not the best you usually
go it's best to go comforter
because the comforter is a shape-shifter
too
[Laughter]
it's like terminator 2 metal
dude that poor memory phone will never
forget
yeah i just want to say you guys are you
guys are both you guys are both skinny
dudes as a fat guy what you're talking
about this is a life or death scenario
we i have to make sure everything is
arid dry yeah down there i use a hair
dryer that's how i know you i make sure
everything's dry and then i have put a
little sun in it you like those
it's not the sun
little trick of the train it's just the
heat
pubes got tips
my paint looks like an 80s skateboard
movie
[Laughter]
playing for keeps over here boys
it is but that that move you see that a
lot with old guys at the gym you don't
see a lot with the younger fellas that's
a nice move it's a great move if you got
the time because it takes a little while
it's also a little dangerous for me for
me it's necessary what heat setting are
you cooking on high
oh i got to blast it out yeah not even
warm hot stains
you're going like five i need it dry
people's lives depend on them if that
starts getting sweaty and starts kicking
up i just ruined it ruins thanksgiving
it would be uncomfortable the heat that
seems like too much heat i like that i
run a little hot down there to begin
with
listen you do that and then you get the
the
wd-40
becomes a layer of acrylic
and then a terracotta no you get the
spray um uh what's it called what's the
deodorant the powder dr bronner's no no
i'm sorry uh [ __ ] dr schulze talcum
powder not tackling powder but the gold
bonds
they got spray gold bond now is that i
think that stuff's not good right that's
all that that's really bad i think yeah
whatever finals doctor said it was okay
[Laughter]
tommy over some martinis
[Laughter]
he was hand-feeding me molly at the time
i'm a big i i haven't done it but there
was a stage in my life where i was the
big i we used just the johnson johnson
baby powder but it was like oh you
didn't open that bad boy up and just
squeeze her down so good it was i had
one time one summer it doesn't make
sense to me at all it's like something
it's crazy you've never done it no it
keeps it fresh and dry
there would be a pancake down there by
the time i was done
it is in fact just talking about is
going to get me back on the train
getting me hooked again and just spray
baby get the spray [ __ ] divine it's
fantastic you get like the menthol
flavor too flavored [ __ ] scented
whatever you call it feel it get that
cool rush it's [ __ ] nice but let me
tell you what i don't do is sit on my
bed and let the [ __ ] sheets dry my
ass
which is what you do you [ __ ]
psychopath that's true and you put your
socks on while you're while your noodles
hanging out oh yeah yeah here's the
here's the here's the
here's the uh immediate flaw with that
what if you got to go back into the
bathroom what if you have to go near
where you where your wet feet stepped
have you ever put fresh socks on and
stepped in water and then gone and put
your shoes on night's ruin i think it's
a little more wet for you i know
honestly no it looks like i did
cannonballs in the shower oh yeah he's
probably a wacky but even though it was
insulting kevin is correct it is very
wet when i get out of the shower it's
it's [ __ ] it's wet i've i there's
been
there's there's been a time or two
there's been a time or two where i put a
[ __ ] wet shoe wet socket to a shoe
but
it's rare it's rare when did the
underwear go on in this process right
after the socks okay so the underwear
sit next to me while the socks go on
okay and then as i get up from bed boom
on the pants on okay
all right and then it's been it's
because i'm a long sock guy that's true
he's a long if you've got if you go
ankle socks
he goes i'll give it to you you can go
ankle sock you can go pants and then
ankle socks and i said well i've for the
past i don't know
20 years of my life i've only worn ankle
socks yeah he's like that is insane
that's that like fifth graders do that
no i was going to say uh that i didn't
know that you were a full sock guy
exclusively i find it incredibly
triggering and disturbing and it's
freaking me out why who's this who's
still a long sock guy since the [ __ ]
ankle socket the ankle sock is [ __ ]
but his is more of a fashion choice as
well yeah he does the cuff that's that's
that's
the cuff on what on his jeans
so he's got the cool sad boy shoes check
him out next time they restock
uh he's got the cool shoes he does like
the cool canvas shoot like yeah you wear
like shoes like that i wear yeah i got a
lot of sneakers yeah and then he does a
pair of high socks and then cuffs the
pants
so you see this yeah
he's a cool guy he's crazy check me out
check me out in murray hill this week
i'll be looking fresh
all right i'll give you that that's
pretty good
yeah
but i still think it's weird that you
wear high socks i i there are times
where sometimes i wish i had anything
like i don't even have any ankle socks
come over my
no it's also half crazy too
you got that from when you were a kid i
bet you were pulling them all the way up
kid weren't you no i was there was a
phase in my life that's why i said to
you it's for fifth graders and people in
ocala the is the ankle sock i used to
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
in college
all right so hold on i have a question
that you might be able to weigh in on do
you remember before i think we've we
might have talked about this before
ankle socks really dropped
midnight mid to late 90s is when they
really [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah they really
dropped and they were like readily
available everything's great time
did you ever have to make your own ankle
sock oh yeah how did you do hell yeah
did you like a lot of people would
you pull it up and then roll it down
yeah like that that was a good one that
was good yeah it ends up your food ends
up looking like an uncircumcised dick
it's true
what i would do was sometimes i would
steal my mom's and cut a little take the
little ripped a little ball off what
yeah like
wait how many pairs of little ball socks
that's a lot
that's your mom a candy striper
that's crazy
does she exclusively wear those your
mama back up singing from frankie valley
high school japanese girl
had a whole drawer also what grown woman
wears this
what mother wears those i could see she
was seven they were they were sporty
they were when she wore her sneakers and
her shorts she had little little ankle
socks and they had like a little puff
ball on the back
yeah i'd rip them off and and use them
as ankle socks yeah
ah i'm the [ __ ] weirdo no your mom is
[Laughter]
i would sometimes not pull it all the
way up and then tuck under
wait hang on dude so like pull like show
your foot
so i would pull the sock down like i
wouldn't put it all the way up pull the
front of the socket
and then fold that under pull that under
yeah that's what you had to do before
[ __ ] you know hanes got their [ __ ]
together and started issuing out ankles
that was a crazy time
walking around in a pair of cargo shorts
with knee eyes
the [ __ ] happening over here america
was in disarray all men walk around
uncomfortable like we're women in shoes
or something it was nice it doesn't even
fit my shoes my
foot's squeezed in here it was bonkers
what you had to do before ankle socks
all right let's run to a couple of
questions this one's been [ __ ]
bonkers uh this one's from insignificant
others uh have you ever taken your own
koozie to a bar are you a koozie guy no
i'm not a koozie guy um
if you do don't usually have the beer in
my hand long enough for it to get warm
i don't think a handful of jack daniels
they don't make koozies for those
did you ever put a t-shirt on your hand
or jacket
um
people do it people come to the shows
that our show are live shows and they
bring their own cousins i got a friend i
got a friend who does it yeah i never
got it i did uh i i went to college in
florida for you know a bit during my
eastern seaboard extravaganza um
but and i was in a frat there's a good
way so i i was a frat boy
for
i was never a frat guy but i was in a
frat sure and uh i'm sure that at that
stage there was a little koozie action
going on yeah but nah yeah i'm over that
that's forgivable yeah of course college
was a wacky time
what's the most amount of alcohol you've
ever snuck into an event or venue
none
i i i'm sure i've done a water bottle of
vodka but that that's the most i've
never been never been a sneaker ringer
really i could see you in a duster with
[ __ ] nine hands
like two kids in a trench coat
i had a credit card on me that i thought
my mom was paying i had no problem with
[ __ ] buying [ __ ]
this kid was paying retail
now don't worry about this
a lot of fellas i got us tonight bali
does
yeah just tell her it's an emergency
i had to go to the pats game
[Laughter]
she's getting alerts on her computer oh
john you foolish boy
falling into my trap again
do you are you are you a guy that would
uh wear sneakers out of the store you're
going to get a new pair of sneaks are
you wearing them out real young kid [ __ ]
yeah yeah i gotta wear them out as a kid
you felt cool yeah god dude [ __ ]
pre-wreck i i got the emmett smith's i
was i had those uh the pennies i wore
those out of the store for sure the
wayne gretzky's the little known sneaker
i don't remember it looks like a goddamn
combat boot it's insane
i think i think they were like an ice
skate without the blade on it they were
like la gears and it's i think i
remember that yeah no it's exactly what
it was i see
the blade on it it is [ __ ] that was
one i will have to wear that so it comes
with hockey laces was la gear and l.a
lighting holy [ __ ] these do not look
cool they look like snowboard boots
they're combat boots dude they look like
what in the [ __ ] is that polish marines
over here how do you say it looks like
some [ __ ] that hitler you should wear
that's got canadian written all over it
that's thing is tough yeah just just
wearing those with a pair of like shorts
and t-shirts to school it was like a
[ __ ] lunatic yeah you wonder why i
was wearing high socks all the time i'd
get blisters on my shins from my
gretzky's
but what about as an adult do you think
that's lame if you wear them out of the
store [ __ ] yeah it is yeah you shouldn't
be in a position where you need to wear
the shoes out i did that maybe two weeks
ago what are you talking something what
you went in there like it was barely
yeah like on your rims or your [ __ ]
shoes i went in there and flip-flops
with socks on
i drove there it was at a dick's it was
at a dick's sporting good in plymouth
meeting i went i was going to buy new
sneakers i was going to get new sneakers
and i was going somewhere afterwards so
why would i wear my own sneakers i wore
my flip-flops how many how many sneakers
do you have one you're a pair yeah you
have two pairs of sneakers how many kids
do you have
that's yeah like it's like a dad move
like yeah i got the ones i cut the grass
in and then the ones that go to work
what do i need more than one pair of
sneakers for i don't know if you were in
a different colored pants one day
no kids
i do yeah
that's what you took out of that
you answered as you know we've met
before right yeah
i'm glad you think i can support a
family though
i'm actually fighter no i got these
jones these ones that i'm wearing right
now no socks
for adidas yeah and those are hurting
these are ready to go you say you bought
those a few weeks ago
these did you go visit the amazon in
between
no i bought another go off rodent again
i bought another pad that i don't like
that are in the trunk of my car i was
thinking so luxe vitalberg's mattress
feitelberg sitting on them things
recently
what is underwear sitting next to it
i've gotten big into shoes now that
we've now that i was always that was a
big thing for us being you know so
[ __ ] poor struggling comics was our
shoes we would literally have to we
would trade shoes sometimes yeah what if
like we didn't if like
i got a pair of shoes that didn't fit or
something we would like get like wear
them and be like i don't like them we'd
have to we'd give each other old shoes
especially we had something coming up
yeah he's got this coming up give him
the jacket yeah yeah
yeah yeah we were sharing clothes it was
bad uh or like we got holes in our shoes
all the time so now like over the past
three weeks i've bought in like
maybe 12 pairs of shoes yeah and i have
like the ones that i like and i just buy
like four pairs
oh
i think these are really these are all
[ __ ] up but i have like four of the
same ones just still in the box from
and i
it's like my claim to fate here's my
problem with that why i can't why i
don't have a bunch of hair which i'd
like to have a bunch of pair is
i go and spend all your money on useless
stuff
fair enough
i go in i go into a store like dicks
they have these
and then you go back the next time and
they don't have them anymore it's some
other but if you like them buy that pair
online do they sell them like that i
thought it was like
i thought it was they were like bagels
like they made they made them some for a
little while then they stopped making
them sneakers yeah like
you went to baby's
like you're right they are shoes have
limited runs yes
but you can still get them just because
you're like when you go to your dicks
and your dicks is out of that shoe
dicks online somewhere still has those
shoes
or pacific sun wear or foot lock or
somewhere
these don't have a name how do i figure
out what the name of the sneakers is air
diabetes
air insulin
so that's what i'm going to do i like
these sneakers i'm going to go home and
figure that out and i'm going to order
five pair so i'm going to wear the same
pair of sneakers a lot of like i think
you're thinking more of like like the
shoes that end up on like stockx and
[ __ ] like that like those are like the
yeah what that is i don't know what that
is he doesn't know what that like it's
like bitcoin
is it on tick-tock
they're like like the exclusive jordan
stuff like that they come out
he just thinks like
a pair of adidas or like yeah yeah i
mean like a few years i think you got a
little while if you can buy a shoe with
like a finish line you've got a little
watch
like every couple of weeks they they
they they
get rid of them it's not a salad bar
like how they put out like now like
dunkin donuts has like you know pumpkin
this pumpkin
but in march
why are you going to fresh baked goods
for clothing products why is that your
equation i don't know fresh sneaks fresh
bagels
wait foley sounds right what's the last
thing you purchase online what's the
last thing i do yeah you're not an
online guy
either i like that oh i purchased a uh i
got a hooker
i've done that
we've seen hookers just watch the
products with them
what yeah we'd come we just like
probably wouldn't right around the time
i was [ __ ] scamming credit cards in
southie uh we just have hookers come
over and we just meet my roommates we
just just watched sopranos yeah they
just come in we'd be like yeah we're
just gonna watch the sopranos and they'd
be like okay and you wouldn't have sex
with them at all they wouldn't [ __ ]
wouldn't even touch them but just give
them a little break
we'd be really [ __ ] up we'd be like
really drunk we just thought it was
funny and it was our little inside joke
we thought it was hilarious though i
don't hate it it's a pretty good pitch
like they didn't like at first like the
first five minutes they're like what the
[ __ ] is happening and then they realize
that we're just watching an episode of
sopranos they got into it they're like
hell yeah this is sick
but i was gonna miss it tonight yeah
they kicked their feet up and i was like
[Laughter]
that story came from me asking foley
what he bought
your question to mature this up a little
bit the last thing i bought online was a
die-cast um x-wing fighter for 136
dollars that's a star wars thing yeah
yeah thanks for turning it up
you bought a star wars toy die cast
metal
you'll probably choke on it
[Laughter]
you answered his joke and then [ __ ]
fact check mine
because okay there's multiple reasons
one you're immature you might choke on
it two you're fat might think it's candy
and eat it
yeah that all checks out that's right
i'm having a good time
i got one more and then we can wrap it
up
um this has been [ __ ]
cuckoo bananas
um
this one i've never thought about it's
from tom p which is a fantastic
indicator
on trash or not i feel how do you
pronounce ralph lauren
ralph lauren ralph no no ralph lauren
sorry you say ralph lauren yes what do
you say i don't know what'd you say
i said lauren but i said it wrong he
said it trashy right no he says he says
he says ralph lauren which one but he
but yeah but i said that i said lauren
but ralph lauren is how he did say it's
i say it loren but i think it is ralph
lauren i believe the correct
pronunciation is lauren i say loretta
was a wrench in the whole mix yeah i
feel like i thought it was loren and the
classy way would be
laurent
a little european on it you know what i
mean
i think he's american isn't he i would
say ralph lauren
it's ralph lauren yeah that's what i
would say ralph lauren it's ralph lauren
t-bone what do you got over there
let me see if i can make this work all
right
ralph lauren
that's google that that that is google
that's not yeah but that's not how he
pronounced that's [ __ ] ai too that's
siri i don't trust her
as far as i can throw her pronounce
ralph
there is another designer named greg
lauren who i think he has
lauren
laurent ralph lauren wow that doesn't
make sense how do you pronounce ralph
lauren
here hold on
ralph lauren i think it is i think it is
that guy sounds like he had money too
i can hear his bottom jaw sticking out
i i saw which is like it's almost like
fake not trashy because i definitely
said loren
my whole life and i think i fairly
recently learned it's lauren okay when
he said how do you pronounce it you said
ralph lauren i said lauren but it's not
i think because i was just saying it
correctly right i think it's it's i said
loren
okay it's like the girl's name okay so
it's ralph it's ralph lauren yeah i got
an official statement from ralph lauren
saying that it's pronounced lauren like
a girl wow okay so you're a jerk off if
you say laurent yes ralph you're trying
to be ralph lauren right yes yeah ralph
lauren yeah it's a little like a lace
curtain so yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
or like
cannoli something
buddy you're the [ __ ] man this has
been a [ __ ] bananas one thank you for
watching i'm glad we got you back it's
been so long i'm glad i got to come in
i've never been in here before you have
we didn't zoom you have proved little
effort of why you are garbage royal
royalty top-notch
and
maybe belongs in a mental institution
i'm not sure
i have to have i have to talk to his
definitely
doctor
30-day rehab
here's what we know
uh what do you got coming up anything
you want the folks out there to know we
are doing uh casey radio oh yeah podcast
uh we're doing the uh with you guys
comedy festival new york comedy festival
we are at the gramercy theater on
november
21
uh friday i think it's like the earlier
show it's like 7 p.m i don't know
exactly about 6 30. i was talking to kfc
last 6 30 it is uh friday november 12th
that is our
show in the city and uh come on out it's
gonna be
super awesome i think we're working on
hiring a circus act to open for us
hopefully so we're going we got we gotta
clear things we're gonna we're gonna
hire uh they're gonna be naked for it
apparently no nudity allowed at the
gramercy theater uh so that's it i'm out
we're trying to figure out what we can
have naked circus people do on stage but
it's going to be a hell of a show it's
going to be a hell of a night absolutely
that's fantastic buddy gramercy theater
look at that looking forward to it don't
miss that one gang kippy what do you got
for him uh same thing uh philly and new
york philly's almost sold out there's
you know
maybe we're talking about 30 tickets
left in philly get those [ __ ] tickets
uh new york also part of the new york
comedy festival we're gonna be at gotham
on uh november
9th at 7 00 p.m get those [ __ ]
tickets that will sell out and then
we're going dark for a little bit no
we're not i just lied we picked up three
more dates we're gonna be in upstate in
new york in december
but that's it gang we love you we'll see
you next week